велика сімка моя продовжу а ти вдома
готові вирішення конфлікту в Україні
процес на саміті джессі він заявив
президент США барак обама озу стригти
якщо драми країни японії президент США
назвав душа продуктивними вибити генцю
те що він витріщив і пару фото бейки
ключові харчування bespeco їх і важливими
для всіх нас штовхнуло
і катували пов'язані з Україною у ми підсіли
батчата фірми порізав переговорах червона
вкрай шим бо чомусь надто багаті
насильства
нам q3 до 2 тис а ви вирішили силу лідери
волоку та сімки знову продемонструвала
їдемо
досвіду не про санкції проти Росії
сьогодні стем зараз санкції необхідно
продовжити і голови crane великої сімки
ось avi посил цієї санкції я ще день
росії ви магата каламутило
позиція євросоюзу також незмінна через його
на полях саміту джессі вен глава
європейської ради дональд туск
айкін я чоловіку смішно це was cool edit
pro з ми в результаті продовжить is sung si
ще до Росії я абсолютно vpn він ще для
чого непотрібно великих дискусій та
спеціального ворона я солідарний
бульбашки не матч він і так вже втратила
Анни зміїну хоча на пародонт не міністр
економіки енергетики фарин зігмар
габріель
та виступив за поетапне зняття санкцій
канцлер ангела Меркель прибувають на
саміті у японії чітко сформулювала
позицію не матч він і поки не varta
враховувати і зміни позицій бардіна
проте головними темами саміту молоко та
75 уроку стала боротьба з тероризмом та
криза біженців глава тримав праведних
crane кольору думалося випробуваю справу не та 3
мільярдів євро іраку для стабілізації
ситуації з мігрантами